il faut aussi garantir que n'importe qui
non plus des produits étrangers qui ne
respectent pas les normes
environnementales que l'on impose à nos
agriculteurs
on impose à nos agriculteurs des normes
environnementales extrêmement strictes
et c'est une bonne chose mais il faut
absolument que ces normes européennes
elles soient respectés y compris pour
les produits qu'on importe un jour et
demi sur cinq nous mangeons des produits
qui y sont importés de l'étranger un
jour et nuit sur cinq et un quart de ces
produits ne respectent pas les normes
environnementales que nous imposons aux
agriculteurs et comme ils sont moins
chers et bien évidemment les français
les consomme c'est une question de
pouvoir d'achat mais pour donner un
exemple la lentille du puy
du puy en velay aujourd'hui est en train
de disparaître alors que la lentille
canadienne qui est importé en france est
là elle contient des pesticides que nous
n'avons pas le droit d'employer en
france donc il faut des clauses miroir
maintenant dans les accords de libre
échange européen ces clauses de libre de
miroirs qui font que plus aucun produit
de l'école n'arrivera en francs en
europe s'ils ne respectent pas les
normes européennes je veux ce choc de
simplification l'on doit des normes et
on doit diviser par deux la durée des
procédures administratives en france
c'est ce que veut le faire d'ailleurs
nos voisins allemands le chancelier
allemand a dit que en allemagne ils
allaient saclay à diviser par deux la
durée des procédures administratives
allemande alors vous imaginez si un chef
d'entreprise doit choisir aujourd'hui
entre la france et l'allemagne il faut
que nous débureaucratisation l'autre
jour j'étais avec un entrepreneur qui me
disait qu'il fallait être sacrément
patriotes aujourd'hui quand on voit la
grande bretagne qui sortit l'union
européenne qui fait vraiment aujourd'hui
comment dire du dumping fiscal et puis
les les agents publics dans un village
qu'ils vous disent qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour vous aider à créer votre
entreprise
on se dit que nous en france on a
beaucoup de travail à faire sur la la
bureaucratie là toutes les normes toute
la paperasse